Uh, but today we have a
very exciting speaker here.
I'll funds out to Villa Alfonzo
and he's here from ames.
He's been with Ames about 10 years and
this just recently become a civil servant.
And before that was a contractor
with Seti working at aims. So,
um, he is currently in the
exobiology branch of Nasa Ames,
uh, looking at terrestrial analog
environments to assess the potential,
how about habitability of other planetary
bodies and developing strategies for
life detection based on first
principles in biology and biochemistry.
Currently he conducts field investigations
in the most extreme deserts on earth,
provide scientific advice for
the maturation of instruments
of space exploration
and helps develop mission concepts to
surf search for as evidence of life on
Mars, Europa. And, and so I'm
selling this and sell it us. Yes.
Thank you. Name. Yes. I'll
know it really well. So, um,
please help me welcome.
I'll find them.
Thank you. Thanks for
[inaudible]. We're calming
and thanks. Everybody was listening
on the radio waves. Um, the,
um,
I'm,
I'm happy to be here and share some of
the latest thinking that our group has
been developing at NASA ames in
terms of the search for life,
specifically the search for a second
genesis of life. So, uh, to begin with,
I'll tell you what the motivation
is for me to be here here.
Meaning aims studying these,
these specific topics and
the way we do it that way.
When I first landed at Ames 10 years ago,
uh,
my mentor back then gave me the most
important advice that I've received in my
career. And he said, the most
important question in science,
you always have to keep asking yourself
is why every time you make a decision,
you decide to do something as yourself.
Why?
And that applies to the questions you're
asking, how you're addressing them,
why you're addressing them that way, why
that experiment, why their observation.
So it's constant. Why, why,
why it takes us today to the kind of
topic did we were talking and discussing.
And it's, as you will see, there's
still a lot of that needs to be done.
But why is the [inaudible] a question
behind all these now itself, this,
this question itself,
it leads to a self doubt and
longterm psychological damage,
but that's secondary. As long as
your science is good, he said, ah,
your papers are going to be solid.
Just keep asking why. And so, uh,
really in asking why are
we searching for a sec?
Why are we searching for life in the
first place? Why should we water? Uh,
and then, uh, starting to
go down the uh, the uh,
chain of reasoning,
the chain of logic.
A lot of these you're going to see today
that's, that's what came out of these,
these kind of asking why now this is
probably the best reason why we should
bother about, we should care about
searching for a second genesis of life.
And some of you might sympathize with
the concept is the zero one infinity rule
is the idea that things,
there are three shapes,
free forms and things can
exist in the universe. Uh,
either they don't or they unique are,
there is many of them really to,
there's no such thing as
two things in the universe.
And so right now we are uh, pause
the zero. There's live on earth.
So we know there is a loose
one example in our equation,
in our equation of life in the universe.
The question is whether it's the unique
one or there is infinite forms of life
and it only takes one other,
in my opinion,
form of life out there that shares does
not share in origin with live on earth
to conclude that there is infinite forms
of life in the universe that's only
based on the sheer number
of exoplanets there are.
We know that are out there and how many
of those we know have likely the right
conditions to support life.
Now,
I'm not going to focus on exit planets
today cause it turns out that our own
solar system already has plenty of places
where life could actually potentially
exist.
The places that in fact a microorganism
micro organisms on earth will be able to
not only survive those environments
were actually thrive in them.
We're going to run through
some of those examples today.
So the motivation is very simple,
fine.
Another example of life so that we
can convince ourselves that life isn't
actually,
it's an actual cosmic phenomenon.
It's not something that happened
once accidentally on our planet.
And so what we're looking for,
as I just said right now,
there is an example of one, there's no
escaping that that motivates the search.
It also limits the way we search because
our knowledge is based on these one
example of life in the universe and as
scientist we've been struggling for many
years on going from a data
number of one to what the,
all the rent to cover all of the
possible range of all the possible,
all the possibilities for
life outside of the planet.
Obviously you're continuously being
limited and constrained by your
understanding of what you know.
And in this case,
what we know is only one live on earth.
The,
despite all its diversity,
when you look at it from the mentally at
the chemical level of life on earth is
very non diverse. It's very,
uh, it's all very similar.
We'll talk about this in a second.
Now what we,
what we really mean by a second.
Genesis of life is exactly this,
a form of life not
related to live on earth.
Now this is a simple statement but
it's not clear to a lot of people and
including a lot of researchers.
What the meaning of a second
genesis really means release. Uh,
something that is not related to us.
It's not something that easy to, uh,
it's not a question that easy
to address. Okay. What's next?
So I'm going to go with for a number of
places I just told you in the secondary
is lots of examples.
Now we know of many exoplanets that are
at the right distance from their parents,
started with liquid water,
could be stable on the surface
that's great for exobiology,
but we're actually interested or I am
actually interested in the possibility of
life in the solar system.
Not for anything but the,
but because of the fact that any
form of life nor in the solar system,
it's almost irrelevant to us.
We will never be able to look at it.
We will never be able to interact
with it in a direct manner.
Just because of the enormous distance
between the, uh, all different stars.
Only a form of life in our solar system
outside of the earth could help us
really understand the basic principles
of life could help us develop a theory of
life because that's a form of light we
could dissect, we could break apart,
we could analyze in detail at the same
way we are. We analyze life on earth,
life on an exoplanet. Awesome.
But other than we know it's there,
it wouldn't really help as
advanced scientifically much, uh,
about the understanding of life and,
and the,
and the way life originated and all these
interesting questions that motivates
the search. Now, it turns out
that there, there is a certain,
there is a fair number of places in the
solar system that we could potentially
think about searching
for evidence of life.
The first one that comes to mind
is present day, Maurice. Um,
we know for a fact that Mars is not,
it's not a habitable planet today.
Anything we know, any form of life we
know of would die on the surface of Mars.
Almost immediately need to exposure of
either toxic chemistry in the soil or UV
radiation. Uh, not,
not to speak about the cold
temperatures and all that nasty stuff,
but we know that conditions on the
surface of Mars do change with time,
just like conditions on the earth.
There are ice ages on Mars,
same way that there are ice ages and
earth triggered by changes in the earth,
orbital parameters of the planet,
and we know that only five to 10 million
years ago conditions on the surface of
Mars,
we're actually warming off to meld some
of these occurrences of ground dies very
close to the surface. These an
impact crater on the surface of Mars.
That happened very recently.
It was actually captured in 2008 there is
a number of documented cases like this.
It was small,
but it was big enough to excavate some
of these white stuff and these white
stuff turns out to be water
ice very close to the surface.
And some of these craters are fun
here in the mid latitudes of Mars.
Actually Vl to here is the
Viking to landing site.
Viking might've missed ground eyes
only by about 10 centimeters. Uh,
back in 1975 research Mars exploration
would have been a lot different if biking
had excavated a tiny bit deeper into
the soil. But the bottom line is that,
uh,
at these low latitudes,
there is examples of ground dies
is very close to the surface,
less than one meter. These ground
eyes can get warming off, uh,
during high obliquity periods for these,
uh,
for these to melt and generate
conditions that it leads,
could be transiently habitable.
So it's a very interesting place to
search for possible evidence of life.
Now I like to think of Mars as
actually a tale of two planets.
Um,
early Mars was a very different planet.
I think of it as different, in fact,
as a different planet. And the way we,
we might want to search for
life in that plan is different.
The way we would search
for life on Mars today.
We know now based on data
from the curiosity rover
that there were legs of Mars
about three and a half billion years ago,
that those lakes would have been habitable
to lifeforms to live the life forms
that exist today on the earth. Even
to us. We could drain that water.
The Ph was okay. The saltiness was
okay, the composition was fine.
There was nothing in that water
will prevent life from growing it.
It had all their,
all their requirements,
nutrients and energy sources to grow
and reproduce that existed on the planet
three and a half billion years ago.
There is evidence that there were many
such examples of habitable environments
on the surface.
In fact,
people have proposed the existence
of a large northern ocean, uh,
in the northern hemisphere of Mars
occupying a big portion off the planet
surface. Uh, and now we have rovers.
The MSL curiosity rover is
studying these sediments,
which was the positive
in that lake environment,
searching for possible chemical
signatures of habitability.
And eventually if a either get lucky,
maybe chemical signatures of life.
Uh,
a big,
a very important first step was the
discovery of organic matter reserved in
those sediments.
Organics is,
we will see is probably the
first requirement you need
as a scientist to decide
to go searching for life on a place
just because the basic fact that life is
made of organic matter.
And so we do have the Mars
Science Laboratory mission
currently studying these
environments.
The exomars,
the European lender is going to go to
Mars in 2020 around 2020 kept getting
delayed but hopefully
2020 is the last one. Uh,
it's equipped to search for evidence
of light using several instruments.
Mars 2020 is another NASA mission.
There is being prepared for a to return
to Mars and maybe would be the first
step towards a sample return mission.
That will be the first mission that would
cash a sample or a number of samples
and would wait for a future mission to
bring those samples back to Earth for
study.
So one possible place to for Mars 2020
to land would be one of those ancient
lake deposits. So lots of
exciting things coming up. Now
a lot of, most of the public is familiar
with this stuff. This is not new,
but what's been developing in the last
few years is the concept of ocean worlds.
Europa, you probably know about that
one. That's the moon of Jupiter.
We know for a fact or as much of a fact
you can get without seeing it directly.
A Europa has an ocean and there an
ice cover of about 90 kilometers,
50 of 60 miles. Uh, that
ocean, it's, it's been busted,
let him pretty much since the Galileo
missions one was 30 or 40 years ago.
But now there is plenty of good evidence
based on morphology and the surface
that there is in fact an ocean of liquid
water under the ice shell and that
ocean is probably about a
hundred kilometers deep.
There's plenty of a water down there.
Recently,
there was indications of the plume of
water vapor ejecting from the surface of
the planet that could be
linked to the subsurface ocean,
although that hasn't been
demonstrated or validated yet.
It's just one observation.
Now these obviously makes it a very
interesting place for life or shouldn't
liquid water, uh, deep far
away from nasty radiation.
That could be an interesting place to go.
Unfortunately technologically
is really hard to get there.
Now the astrobiology community,
the planetary science community in general
has been always interested in landing
on the surface of Europa.
Uh,
for many we thought it will take
a not of God to actually do that
technologically is vacant picketed.
It turns out it would be, it, it, it,
it actually it was worth more than that.
It actually took an act of Congress
for us to go to the surface of Europa.
But last year Congress actually provided
some decks demanding or asking NASA to
actually put together a mission to land
on the surface of Europa in the next
decade and not only the land
but also to search for life.
That got everybody very intrigued,
very excited. And there is currently a,
there's going to be a call for
instruments at the end of this year,
early next year for the
community to propose instruments
that would logo on that
lender and that would probably
land on Europa hopefully, uh,
within the next 10 years. And they
would go to a place on the surveys,
probably one of these caves regions,
which morphologically they look like
it's actually upwelling of ground water
from the ocean going all the way through
the ice cover and then freezing on the
surface.
So it will be a mission that without
accessing directly the ocean would still
might still be able to analyze ocean
materials. It's very exciting mission. Now
there is another exciting place
in the solar system that's titan.
That's a moon of Saturn. Titan is very
interesting because it's very alien.
It's probably the most alien place in
the solar system in the sense that it's
very different from everything else.
It's a moon of a fairly large sizes,
the largest moon of Saturn.
Uh,
but the interesting thing about
titan are these spots on the surface,
mostly in the northern hemisphere
of the moon, which our lakes,
but they're not legs of water,
their legs of hydrocarbon,
they're mostly made off matte
liquid methane, liquid ethane.
That's what makes the moon interesting.
An alien at the same time,
it's because there's nothing really,
there is about these days familiar to us.
Liquid methane happens at man,
it's 150 degrees
centigrade. So it's an environment
that we don't really understand,
but there has been models proposed by
scientists on how life could actually
exist in these lakes. It will be
live and like anything we know of,
obviously we can not even imagine the
biochemistry of those forms of life.
It wouldn't be water based,
it could be carbon based,
but it will be a chemistry completely
different from what we're used to.
So it's actually really hard to come up
with ways of searching for evidence of
life. Uh, on Dighton does, you
don't really know where to begin.
But there has been several
missions proposed to go to
titan within the next 15,
20 years. Um, and some of them are
actually being considered as we speak, uh,
by a review panel at Nasa, uh,
for flight in the next, uh, in an,
in an upcoming run missions. So data
is very interesting, very alien.
But my favorite place,
it's actually Enceladus and settle.
This is a tiny moon. Maybe you know of
it because it was in the news recently.
It's been in the news for a while,
but recently it made a big splash.
I'll tell you in a second way
then sell it as a tiny moon.
It's about the diameter between
here and La. It's not a big one. Um,
but it's unique in the sense that he
has this active gazers coming out of the
surface.
This is an actual picture of Enceladus
they can buy the Cassini mission and in
the South Pole of the moon you can see
here that picture center at the South
Pole. There is these features
here, features on the surface.
These are called Tiger stripes.
These are cracks in the ice shelf,
in the shell of the moon.
And through this crux,
there's stuff venting into space
that was discovered by Cassini.
And arbitrary in the Saturn system that
NASA and the European sent together in
the 1923 2003,
uh,
took this has been investigating this
month for the last then in 2015 years.
Now the Cassini is just plunging into
Saturn as we speak to the end of the
mission. But through the lifetime
of the mission, we've been able to,
NASA has been able to fly that spacecraft
through the plumes of Enceladus
multiple times and study the
chemistry of those plumes.
It turns out that those blooms are
made mostly of water. They contain CO2,
methane, ammonia and hydrogen.
This is great for microbes. These,
this candy for some microbes is an energy
source for micro organisms on earth.
On top of that, we know that those
gazers contains salts, sodium,
just very similar to the salts that make
up the ocean of the earth and they also
can contain pain is silica
grains a few nanometers.
Silica is the staff that is made in
hydrothermal vents at the bottom of the
ocean.
And organics seems to be lots of organics,
apt to, at least Cassini detected
at two carbons six organics.
Carbon six a is was the limit
of detection of the instrument.
They couldn't see things bigger than
carbon six for a number of reasons.
So the expectation is that
there are probably more
complex organics in the ocean
and all those samples are
coming into space for free.
And so they're just waiting for us to
send a spacecraft and continue looking at
that chemistry for free.
Maybe not for free,
maybe your hand it hand and $50 billion,
but once we get there,
the samples are for free. So, um,
recently, uh, uh,
our team at Nasa Ames in collaboration
with Goddard space flight center and the,
uh, uh, APL laboratories at
Johns Hopkins University,
we will propose the mission
to do precisely that,
the return to end sellers and search
for evidence of life in the applied
materials coming out of the South Pole.
Now that mission gets selected by NASA,
it's going to make it there somewhere
sometime in the mid twenties, thirties.
Um, I, I expect to be there. Weed
smoking started running. So, um,
uh,
but it's one of those things that shows
you how complicated technological it is.
Missions can be because of the distance,
because of the complexity of the
science in all these type of things.
But in the meantime, we have 25 years to
figure things out. That's the good news.
And so we keep studying the,
uh,
all the data that comes back from Cassini
and that just wanted to share with you
some letters, results of a conceptual
model. We build very simple model,
but they think it's very
important based on Cassini data.
So told you the Cassini detected
hydrogen coming out of the, uh,
of the plume and he also can
a detected silica grains.
The Silica has already been linked to
hydrothermal vents at the bottom of the
end sellers ocean.
So this would be a cross section of the
moon with the ice shelf and the plums in
the southern hemisphere.
We know that there is an ocean based
on the composition of the plumes.
We know that there is hydrothermal
activity at the ocean sediment interface
based on the presence of those
silicon nanoparticles. Um,
now when we take the composition,
that composition that comes out of
Cassini and we put it in the ocean and we
shake it and we run our geo chemical
models, it turns out they're all that gas,
hydrogen and methane there.
It's been detected in the plume has to
be forming here at the bottom of the
ocean. And as quickly,
as soon as it forms,
it's actually starts bubbling because
there is so much guys that it's actually
above the hydrostatic pressure.
And then that guy's forms,
bubbles and those bubbles with
the bubbles. Do they rise?
They like to go up and we've been running
some models to estimate how big those
bubbles would, how fast they
would rise, how big they would be.
Turns out it might be enough gas
in there to mix the entire ocean,
which is good for us,
but most importantly,
it's enough stuff to bring
hydrothermal vent fluids.
This is an example of a picture from
the ocean on the earth where you can see
the hydrothermal vents, uh,
pumping fluids into the ocean.
These fluids could go straight up into
the plumes in about timescales of,
uh,
several months.
Earth months just aided by
these rapid raise of bubbles,
which means that we're,
we're sampling in the moon actually has
a significant amount of hydrothermal
material living in there.
Why is that important?
Because we know that there are microbes
on the earth that's like to grow around
these hydrothermal vents.
Also shrimp and other stuff we don't
inspect shrimp on and some others, but,
but the microbes, the microbes would
be enough and they will be fine.
If we have an ecosystem of microbes
developing at the bottom of these
hydrothermal vents using that hydrogen
and methane and CO2 and nutrients to grow
and reproduce some of those microbes,
or at least their decay products,
they could get and trained in
these rising plume come back, uh,
shooting through the,
through the gazers,
I mean through the plumes on the surface.
Now our spacecraft could catch those
microbes or the chemistry associated to
them and maybe find evidence for life.
So this is that these gets may five stars
as the most interesting destination in
the solar system. Uh, even vacation
will be interesting there. So, uh,
now the question that brings us at this
point is there is obviously the search
for life. The search for a second, Janice,
I hope that I convince
you that it's timely.
We now have plenty of destinations
to go to. Um, and it's real.
It's a, it's a reality. I'm
not saying there is live there,
I'm just saying that all the conditions
we could hope for our med there.
So there is no really a excuse now to
continue investigating. Now the question,
next question is how do we
discover a second genesis of life?
That's what's going take is mostly of
the rest of this, of the talk. Now,
up until recently,
this pretty much what our understanding
of a extra tray. So forms of life, uh,
aliens are typically
defined geographically.
If something is not a part of the planet,
it must be an alien.
Must be a second genesis of life. But
that really, that's not, that's nothing.
That's not a statement. They
scientifically, uh, you,
you can support it with
scientific data just yet. Uh,
there's been plenty of models tossed
around about Panspermia probably you are
familiar with the concept and Panspermia
is the transfer offline between
planetary bodies. There are actually
different flavors of Panspermia.
There has been a, the most unlikely
type of Panspermia you can think of.
It's interstellar panspermia the transfer
of life between distance solar systems.
Now these models, the only reason
they're considered is, is the, uh,
because the probabilities are so low.
The only things that make,
the only thing that makes these models
palatable to a scientist is the enormous
time at the university has been around.
And so when you factor in time,
then anything is possible.
Uh, but we're not, uh,
Panspermia fans are not really a
cleansing their hubs on these interstellar
Panspermia. There Mosley thinking on two
different types of more local panspermia
commentary.
Panspermia Planetary Uplink Twinsburg Mia.
The first one commentary is the idea that,
uh,
our solar system didn't
come out of nowhere. Uh,
our son him from the um,
um,
accumulation of gas that resulted from
the explosion of a previous sun as far as
we know it now probably that sign also
had planets based on what we know about
sons in the universe.
People have proposed that if life evolved
on that previous solar system or any
of the previous solar systems that
existed before our own in the same spot in
the universe,
and those forms of life could have been
a hanging around while the planets were
forming and then come back to
colonize the right planets back again.
That's commentary Panspermia
at some people have postulated
that the universe is
actually percolating with.
It's very curated with uh, uh,
materials that contain,
contain forms of life preserved in them.
And that could be sitting the
universe throughout. Now you can, the,
the interesting thing about
Panspermia is it might deliver or not.
It doesn't matter. Believe he's
not a scientific, a valid approach.
There is nothing that that
suggests that this theory is wrong.
And that goes at the,
that goes to the core of the problem of
how we search for a second genesis of
life and why we need to search
for a second genesis of life.
The last one is the one you know
probably you're more familiar with its
planetary Prince Permian is the concept
that planets after they formed in the
solar system,
they've been literally exchanging
spit a back and forth early on.
They were younger, they were more
uh, okay, I'm now going to go there.
But there was a lot of exchange going
on early on in the history of the solar
system. It's plenty of
meteorites from Mars and earth.
There is mere rides from Earth on Mars.
People have actually estimated the
probability given a number of factors of
lives transferring between planets
starting on Earth Ground Zero.
Even that 13% chances than biological
material could be actually successfully
transferred to Venus.
Not An small chance of lives transformed
tomorrow's back and forth. Actually,
if people have postulated an origin of
level Mars and later transferred to Earth
based on the number of
Joe Chemical prisons,
even places like Europe and then sell
this, there is a, there is more but still,
uh, existing probability that life
could be transferred between them.
So the bottom line of this is that
you cannot assume that aliens can be
geographically defined.
Geographics then apply to aliens and
Liz and less we know unless we find a
second example of flavor can we can
use to prove it. So these, uh, review,
this needs to revision.
We need to update our concept,
how we treat aliens in
many different ways.
Um,
and so the question then comes,
so how do we search for a second genesis?
If we can just go find life somewhere
else and claim second geneses then how do
we search for it?
And I'm going to go through as through
a short thought process that I'm
hopefully exemplifies the
way we've been doing this.
We've been going about this business
for the NAM a number of decades now.
Certain flight, but I'm gonna
use a different example. So they,
this picture of the universe and we know
now that there are more planets than
stars in the galaxy and there
is plenty of galaxies out there.
So there is a large number
of planets out there.
And now think for a second that
earth is the only planet we know.
There's no other planet in the solar
system. Earth is now a number one.
Everything we know our planets
is captured in the earth.
And uh, we decided to search
for other planets out there.
Are there other planets
other than the earth?
We could devise an experiment
where we take our planet,
we look at the way it's made, the way
it's built, the composition, the shape,
the size and everything.
And we can define a series of what
we would call planet signatures.
And then we could go,
we could,
we could build a telescope and started
searching for planets out there based on
the presence or absence of
those planets signatures.
We could try to search for
direct imaging morphology.
If we see something that moves, started
the move, if something moves a wonder,
there should be a planet we could,
we could look for that.
We could look for a motion,
we could look for unique compositions.
We know that the atmosphere
of the earth is very unique.
It's very unlikely to exist
somewhere else, uh, especially,
uh,
in places like stars or rock stars.
And so if we see an anomaly of
nitrogen and oxygen, for example,
we could claim that there
is a planet out there.
Now you can guess this is not a very
efficient way of looking at planets.
And in fact,
that's not how we look at planets.
The way we look at planets around
other stars is by a number of methods.
But mostly they're focused on looking
at a star and looking for anomalies in
what we know about that star. In this
case, the anomalies represented as a law,
as a decree,
as a decline in brightness.
So here we have a spectrum of
the brightness of the star.
In this case is actually, I think this
is Venus going around our own son.
The same applies to other planets.
And we see how when the planet
crosses in front of the star,
the brains of the star of the
quizzes in a predictable way.
Now obviously this is not what we see
when we look at exoplanets is what we see
when we look at exoplanets,
we actually see the planet.
Bottom line is we don't need to look for
planets in order to search for planets.
We don't need to look
for planets signatures.
What we need to do is we need to focus on
something that we understand very well,
whose physical laws are very well
understood and see if there is any,
anything in those in the behavior of
that object that doesn't come that cannot
be explained by what
we know about physics.
There's in fact the way we search
for planets, maybe not consciously,
but it's a very robust way of looking
for planets because you're not
presupposing anything about
those planets evolve. Evolve.
When Neil was that planets
are made of oxygen,
have an atmosphere of oxygen and nitrogen
and that they are the size of the
earth.
They look blue and that's all we look for.
We'd still be looking for planets today
and we will put in there, found anyone,
uh, we need to be able to search for
planets with, are looking for planets.
This covering planets without
searching for planets.
Now that's not how we've been searching
for life despite we also start with the
data number of one. What we do,
people normally scientists do,
they come up with biosignatures instead
of planet signatures and then they start
searching for those
biosignatures in other planets.
And that just makes the same sense.
It's looking for planets, signatures,
in my opinion, when your database,
all your data is based on one,
any see any signature you look for a
is suspect of what we call confirmation
bias.
You're not searching for something,
you're confirming that something is there.
You assume there is something there
that has these in these properties.
You just want to confirm your assumptions.
Now,
this is not something we do on purpose,
but it's something that
it's underlying every, uh,
every effort to search for life out there
and that I think it's a big important
problem. So the question is, no, it's not.
How do we discover a
second genesis of life?
The question is how the whiskey cover a
second genesis of life without searching
for life. And that's an interesting
question. How do you go about this?
Can we have,
can we find a way to search for live
the same way we search for exoplanets?
And so to do that we actually have to go
back and obviously look at what we know
and what we know is live on earth. This
is probably, you're familiar with it,
that just a representation of the
tree of life there is simplified.
But this covers our family tree
for the last 4 billion years.
Uh,
we are up here now at the tip of the Oak.
Harriet's a team is not something
[inaudible] in evolutionary biology.
This could be a dead end for us.
The fact that we are up in the branches
doesn't mean that we're better or worse.
It just means that we're
up in the brunches. Um, uh,
would we know of based on
these organization of the
tree that there is a lot of
interesting and useful information we
can learn about life on earth and we can
extract some that, some of
that information, uh, in, uh,
and apply it to strategy search for life
somewhere else. So we know for example,
and we'll talk about these in a second,
that all the major groups of
life on earth, the bacteria,
the archaea and they will carry it.
These two are small unicellular organisms,
all of them,
the precarious,
we all come from the same last universal
common ancestor called the looker down
here. Last universal common ancestor.
We all branched out of the same one,
the same successful one,
but this was not the origin of life.
The origin of life on earth happened
somewhere here with what we call the
organism or the original organism.
Uh,
that was our founding organism.
Um,
and there was a period we know,
or there must have been a period we know
of intense evolution between the origin
of life and loca where there's was
a lot of biochemistry going on,
a lot of trial. And
error. A lot of mutations,
a lot of organisms trying
to figure things out.
Even there could have
been things branching out.
The disappeared eventually because they
weren't successful enough or there were
infinity enough and there is
no record of those anymore. Uh,
we'll go back to this issue of how far
into these periods we can look at in a
few seconds because that's important.
But we can take this basic structure
of life on earth and we could just do a
quick thought,
a thought exercise on what possibles,
what possibilities are out there
in terms of a second genesis,
how would a second,
Janice is related to these,
obviously what we mean
essentially by a second.
Genesis is a form of life that
is not related to these guys.
That's what we mean by a second.
Genesis, no more, no less. Uh,
we're not assigning locality to a second.
Genesis.
There could have been a second genesis
on earth for as far as far as we know,
when people have postulated, uh, uh,
second geneses at a second biosphere on
the earth lurking in the shadows that
biochemical is independent from us
now has never been found. But it did.
Interesting idea.
Uh,
we're looking for a second
genesis something and related
to us or regionally. Uh,
but we can constrain this space of
what's possible we can possibly find out
there just by making
some basic assumptions.
So essentially that's goes back to our
original idea. There is a prebiotic world.
There is no life.
An origin of life event happens on
our planet that led to interesting
biochemistry, the RNA world and
whatnot. And eventually, uh,
the mother and organisms
branching out until today. Now,
if we go to Mars and we find a form of
life and we can do all the chemistry,
we don't, we do two living organisms, uh,
and it turns out that we can
map these organisms back.
That's what it's gonna look like.
It's going to map somewhere
in our tree of life.
It's not going to be a second genesis.
That's one possibility that life out
there actually shares a common ancestry.
We will be able, we might
be able to look to, to uh,
to establish that second possibilities.
What I see I call a close second geneses.
That would be an example of a form of
life that is independent from us in origin
but it came out of the same kind of soup
organic soup and we'll talk about a in
a few slides of what we mean by the same
kind of soup or we could talk about a
distance second genesis and there will
be a form of life completely unrelated to
us coming out of uh,
coming out of a very different type of
probiotic soup that we couldn't even
begin to imagine.
Although actually you might think of a
couple of split one plays in the solar
system where that might happen.
So here's what I propose as the solution
to how to come out of this conundrum.
How can we establish whether some plays
in the solar system contains a common
ancestor or a close second geneses
or a distant second genesis.
It goes back to something we are familiar
with since the 1930s the theory of
organic chemical evolution you may be
familiar with with this theory of your
read about the origin of life.
That's the theory that debunks the idea
that life is a spontaneous generation.
It live instead propose
that life is just another,
it's a continuum in the process of organic
chemical evolution in the universe.
It's a very interesting theory.
It's in fact the theory means that
it's supported by a lot of evidence.
It's right now is the most successful
explanation of how chemistry happens in
the universe, all the way
to uh, thinking organisms.
Now, there are four tenants. The
theory of organic chemical evolution.
The first one is that there is chemistry
going on in the universe with or
without the presence of life that results
in the synthesis of organic or small
organic molecules like
amino acids and nucleotides.
These are molecules we're familiar with
because those are parts of our, what?
Biochemistry, but they're
done. It's not live.
It's not required for
amino acids to exist.
The second tenant is that
they are a combination of
these small molecules forms,
larger molecules called polymers.
And that can happen again with
or without the presence of life.
Now in the case of at least
one planet in the universe,
the combination of those polymers
eventually resulted in small droplets,
self organized droplets that we call
protopia loans that will be the first
organisms.
And uh,
fueled by the process of evolution
by natural selection. Darwin,
those pro a pro by owns, uh,
became more and more complex,
eventually figured out how to
transfer information between different
organisms.
And that just cascaded
into a huge complexity.
It's still chemical complexity.
The bottom line of the fury of organic
chemical addition is that these are steps
that just [inaudible] off one from
the other. We'd done, we'd done,
we cannot separate them.
We don't need to separate them.
We can separate evolution by natural
selection from the origin of life,
from prebiotic evolution,
from basic prebiotic chemistry.
It's all part of the same continuum. And
because it's part of the same continuum,
this should be fairly frequent
in the universe. It's,
there's nothing here that it's earth lead
it related at please not as far as we
know,
unique to the earth.
So here's a representation of the
same idea in the case of the earth.
So here you have the four stages in the,
in their organic chemical evolution.
We start with the NAB, with the Solar
Nebula, the beginning of the uh,
the better beginning of the solar system.
We know that there were compounds,
very basic molecules like water,
uh, ammonia, methane, [inaudible].
That stuff is all over the universe.
Uh, it was probably president,
our Nebula when the
planets, sorry, the form,
you have room for more complex
chemistry, uh, that uh,
these molecules react and they generate
other basic molecules like amino acids.
Nucleotides were not.
Eventually when the planet calls down,
these things can grow into
larger more complex molecules.
Think of it as a process of
crystallization. The same way as lava,
a hot Floyd where everything is
mixed and everything is, is chaotic.
When it starts to call, call
down, it starts to crystallize.
And then you have big structures
for me. Hub, you can think of this.
Chemistry in a similar way eventually
starts to crystallize into complex forms.
Now there is a singular event,
the origin of life on earth where
these things moved from free,
floating a complex molecules into
something very complicated membranes,
proteins,
uh,
genetic material that eventually evolved
through the process of their reading
and evolution into very complex
organisms up until today.
But it's all part of the same
continuum of increasing complexity.
Now, why is that important? While there
is plenty of evidence of that, uh,
these are amino acids, sugars,
lipids, and nuclear basis.
These are the four basic
ingredients of our biochemistry.
Any biochemistry on earth is based on
those four types of basic comp compounds.
And this is examples of those
compounds. We find a mirror rates, um,
all four of them.
This is the list of amino acids that
have been identified in meteorites so far
that and that they're known
to be non-terrestrial. Uh,
you can read all of them here,
but about half of the immuno acids we
used to from our proteins are in these
table and they're not biogenic.
The same with sugars.
We tend to use this type of sugars here.
There is plenty of sugars and mid rates.
These are tiny cell like structures that
are formed when you put some meter aids
in water.
Those meteorites have molecules,
lipid fat like molecules that when they
put them in water and you dissolve the
media raid,
they actually form these satellite like
structures which have some resemblances
in many different ways to our own cells
and these are the nucleobases that form
our DNA and RNA or DNA and RNA
are made a free basic molecules.
One of them or the nuclear basis, and
these are the clubs is find in meteorites.
Now you can see it here. Limpets they're
finding live. They're finding me rides.
They useful for membranes, sugars. Again,
they're life. They're finding me right,
so you should useful for energy.
When we don't see meteorites are polymers,
large sugars. That's the stuff of life.
We make large stuff. We make big stuff.
A meter rides don't the same with amino
acids. They're finding meteorites,
but we don't have proteins or bay
complex polymers of amino acids to rides.
And the same with nuclear basis.
You don't see it here because
I'm a in front of it. But um,
there are nucleobases as I
just showed you in meteorites,
but there are not big polymers
of nucleobases. Oh, it's
down there. There you go.
Yeah.
Now
it's very important that that realization
that our chemistry is just the basic
evolution, all of organic chemistry
in the Universal Chemistry.
It's very important.
I tried to summarize the importance of
it in this diagram and I'll try to walk
you through that. Um, we have,
we know there is prebiotic chemistry.
I just showed it to you with pictures,
actual pictures from the early solar
system that we had a spacecraft they can
pictures down there and we
know that there was a Nebula,
they're full of chemicals. There was no
spacecraft at the early solar system,
this closure. But anyway, uh,
we know that there was prebiotic chemistry
from which live on earth originated
at the origin of life.
And evolved into complex multicell
organisms based on the abundance of those
same compounds in the solar,
in solar system materials we could
expect that live on Mars with probably
originate from a similar soup of compounds
and they're very similar conditions
and by similar conditions I mean
water chemistry under 10 temperature,
Ph and solidity similar to
any environment on the earth.
And so I would call,
yeah,
live on Mars if he'd ever existed a close
second geneses because it's probably
evolving from the same
kind of starting materials,
not too far off to think that way.
I would actually go as far as to say
that live on your opine and sellers would
probably also trays back if it
turns out they exist and we started,
we can study their biochemistry,
we can also,
we can probably trace back their
biochemistry to these prebiotic soup,
the same starting materials because
the same basic ingredients were used to
build those,
those roles.
Now there is room for transfer
of flight between planets.
I just told you about Panspermia
so we can always have,
we always have to leave these up,
these possibility open,
but any of those three planets is
sufficiently similar to the earth that we
could postulate the presence in them
have a close second genesis of life. Um,
whereas Dayton, you can think of
Titan as it plays that if he has life,
it should be a very
different chemistry from us.
It probably started with
very similar materials,
but they quickly enable any process
of organic chemical evolution in very
quickly probably led to something very
different from what we know and if it was
life, which tends to speed up
this process of complexity,
then whatever we have there,
it's something that we can not
really comprehend it until we see it.
So I called that as a list
and second genesis of life.
Okay,
now that, why that, why is that important?
Because that's chemistry we can play with.
If you tell me that live on Mars,
probably it was a close second geneses
and he makes sense to think that way.
I know how to distinguish.
I know how to tell whether there
was life there at some point or not.
I'll try to convince you of that in a
second. I think we're running out of time,
right?
Um,
what I say is that because we
really tend to be scientist,
guess what,
we tend to be over optimistic.
We always tend to assume that there
was life on Mars. And so again,
we go back to the confirmation bias.
All we would have to do is to confirm it.
That's why we think about searching
for cells or movement or a crawling.
Reptiles are growing plants or things
like this. Our signatures. In fact,
what we should do is what I propose
these two fold I policies, uh,
that puts yourself in the worst case
scenario to address this fundamental
question.
The question is not whether there is
life on Mars and syllabus or Europa.
The question is how far the organic
chemical evolution go in those planets?
How far there you go. They go as far
as the earth, probably not. Otherwise.
There will be somebody giving a talk
about this or Mars looking back at the
earth.
Uh,
but you don't know in the spectrum of
organic chemical evolution how far it
could have gone.
Maybe it stopped at the prebiotic
chemistry and that's all we see,
but in any case,
that's the question we need to ask and
these are the two hypotheses we need to
falsify. Falsifying is a very
important thing in science.
We need to prove these
two things to be wrong.
The first one is that is the a [inaudible]
signal hypothesis and that means that
organic chemical evolution on Mars,
Europa or Enceladus never went beyond
the prebiotic chemistry and all the
chemistry we will see there is consistent
with robotic sources. The second one,
if we can falsify that one,
if we can go to any of these places,
run our organic chemistry kits and we
figured out that we cannot explain that
chemistry based on everything we know
about a body chemistry than something else
must explain it. That's something
else I propose these earth life,
it's either because of the process of
Panspermia or because of contamination,
planetary protection,
the stuff we brought with us there.
If we can prove this wrong,
then we have a good case for
a second genesis of life.
But not until we have proved
these two hypotheses wrong.
Now the first one I had thought that
the second one would be the easy one.
It turns out that, uh, I'm, I'm still,
as I keep thinking through this logic,
it turns out the dye might not be the
case. I'll tell you why in a second.
The first one that's in
the Abe articulate bothers.
It turns out that it's not that
hard to do if you think about it.
Cause if you keep thinking on this
framework, organic chemical evolution,
the universe, it's very lazy at making
stuff. It doesn't really like to make big,
complicated stuff. Likes to make a
lot of simple stuff. That's why water,
carbon nitrogen, that's mostly
the composition of the universe.
And in terms of organics,
amino acids, a few sugars,
some nuclear basis and a lot of graphite
there is really, it's like, okay,
that's it.
That's as far as I'm going to go.
And there is a predictable actually
pattern in the comp in the complexity of
organic chemistry that you can
expect in the absence of life.
That's what you see here
exemplified in the case off.
I think these are amino acids.
These are plots of showing carbon number
and I mean a lot to these hydrocarbons.
This is carbon number.
So the more carbons or molecule
has the more complex it is,
the harder it is to build.
And this is what you see in terms of
carbon number distributions or abundances
in hydrocarbons,
molecules made of cartilage,
carbon and hydrogen in in a biotic
systems here is in hydrothermal vents,
a directly sampled in the ocean and also
in hydrothermal simulations in the lab.
There's a lot of methane with one carbon
and there is a tiny bit of ethane and
propane and there is almost nothing
of anything bigger than carbon six.
And you can see the same distribution
in meteorites. You can see the same,
the situation in a organic chemistry,
uh,
experiments in the laboratory.
We always end up with these ex exponential
decay in abundance as a function of
carbon numbers.
A here is what I would think to do
if I was going to go to Enceladus.
Actually Cassini has already done some
of the groundwork because CD has an
ally's hydrocarbons coming
out of the plume of Enceladus.
These are the distribution
of these thoughts there.
They fall down the exponential decay line.
Now unfortunately Cassini could see
on the app the carbon six or so.
I told you that in the beginning so we
don't really know what's going on in the
plume up there.
If there was no life,
the prediction would be that the abundance
of hydrocarbons larger than six or
seven carbons would be like this one.
There will be nothing there.
But if we go there and we sampled the
plume and we started to see weird stuff,
that's not something we can explain
based on their battery chemistry. Now,
I haven't made it any position or any
assumption on the biochemistry of forms of
life on Enceladus. I'm just saying that
I cannot explain that a biologically.
And so something else must be explained
that and that just for the case of
hydrocarbons,
if we look at amino acids,
is a very similar story
because the universe always
works in mysterious ways. Uh,
it likes to make a particularly small
amino acid, two carbons, three carbons.
That's mostly the staff you'll
find in meteorites and stuff. Uh,
and then very few of the very
large carbon amino acids,
except when you look at life,
and these are the red dots here.
These are all our amino acids.
The relative abundance of
immuno acid in ourselves,
a nine of them is higher than 10%.
We don't care how many
carbons the immuno acid has.
We care about what that amino
acid glass for us. And so if it,
if we need a 10 carbon immuno acid,
we'll invest the energy to build
those 10 carbon immuno acids.
And so what we'll end up with is and a
biotech distribution that's predictable
and he did an exponential decay on
with carbon number and any other non,
uh, exponential distribution
is not something that we
can explain a biologically,
not saying it, it's not a
biotic, but until we find a
neighbor Arctic explanation,
uh,
the best alternative is a form of life.
Now
this is an example of that same principle.
This is the amino acid.
These are six, five,
seven amino acids that are commonly
found in meteorites and in organisms on
earth.
This is the abundance that we see for
those immuno acids in carpet with carbon
number.
That's two carbon numbers.
These are I think five
carbon numbers in meteorites.
You see the exponential decay in life,
you see a very different pattern.
So that's the stuff we need to look for.
Now
the second I bought disease,
if we go to sellers and we have these
distributions that we cannot explain it
[inaudible] then we need to show that
it's not stuff that we brought with us or
it's tough that was
transferred between planets.
That's what we call the
terrestrial null hypothesis.
And I have thought that that would be
the easy one because we do that all the
time, all the time on the
earth. We study ancestry.
That's what we do when we
look at DNA and proteins.
We tried to establish and gestural
relations between organisms.
So if we go to Enceladus,
uh,
it should be fairly easy to establish
ancestral relations and and terming
whether they came out of our three
or they came from a different tree.
Now the problem with that is,
and that's where I'm going to stop.
So we could look at all these molecules,
DNA on earth, non DNA, a second,
genesis, three letter, genetic
code, Different Code. Uh,
we look for different types of proteins
or different sales structures and all
that good stuff. Now here's the problem
though. That's where I'm stopping.
We go back to our famous tree of life.
It turns out that everything
we know about biochemistry,
because of the virtue of how
life on earth has evolved,
can only be really trace back to Luca,
the last universal common ancestor.
You can think of that, or at least I
think of that as a biochemical horizon.
We cannot see beyond that biochemical
horizon because we've lost all that
information. No photo albums off
of our family before look at,
there is no nothing preserved
in the rocks other than shapes.
There's no chemistry projecting the
rugs. It was too, too long ago. So we,
we can't really tell what
biochemistry was back then.
All we know about biochemistry
stops and starts with Luca.
And so any biochemical difference
becomes between live on earth or another
planet.
It becomes questionable whether it implies
a second genesis or implies a common
ancestor.
And that's even more so when we start
looking for a close second genesis that we
all came up or the of the same
soup because we never know.
We will never know the exact composition
of the first organism. It's, it,
it might be impossible to actually tell
a close second genesis from a common
ancestor. That's what my thinking was as
off 10:00 AM this morning. And so, uh,
maybe I come up with a better
idea later today, but, uh, that's,
I think it's a very interesting
question to think about. Uh,
it might be an actual limitation in our
understanding of cert on how we search
for life in the universe. And so just
to leave some time for questions,
I'll leave you with the conclusions.
They just summarize what I just said.
We can read them as we are. If you have
questions, I'll be happy to answer them.
So thank you very much.
[inaudible].
So my question is,
as far as we know,
it's apostle tuff life does not,
not based on it
biochemistry.
Well we will call it bio chemistry.
It might be a different,
very different types of biochemistry.
The moment you talked about life
live by chemistry, there's no names.
It's anonymous kind of thing.
It might be not carbon based.
That's probably what you're
more thinking about it.
Oh yeah.
Or even similar to AI.
All different dimensions you can,
if you can have AI evolving from nothing.
Like it varies.
If you can come up with a theory of
silicon organic or evolution or silica
evolution, uh, then yes.
A base that our assumption
is that any AI was,
uh,
comes not from spontaneous
or a spontaneous chemistry,
but from biochemistry,
you need biochemistry for ar to exist.
That's an interesting question. Uh, if we,
if we want to go into the concept
of artificial, that's, oof,
we can have another talk
about that artificial,
but something similar to
the composition of Ai,
like in that it's very ritual that
people have proposed silicon based life,
but they weren't thinking of microchips.
They were thinking of the actual
element and how it could sustain about
chemistry analogous the carbon.
But silicon based life has very different
properties. It's very constrained.
And in reality,
I mean obviously you can never reject
the idea of silicon based life again,
but the element, not the microchip, uh,
but it's not an accident
that we're made of. Carbon.
Carbon is the third most abundant element
or fourth more abundant element in the
universe. And the other one is
oxygen, nitrogen, hydrogen and helium.
So other than the helium,
we're pretty much covered the entire
wheel state of the university in terms of
elemental composition. There
is no accident that we're
made of that stuff. Um,
there might be weird things out there,
but for those weird things to exist,
they will,
they would have to be a
process of chemical destination
where carbon is removed
from the equation and therefore
allows weird silicon stuff to evolve.
Uh, when it comes to AI, I think for, uh,
behind every intelligent being there
is a bacteria at least evolutionary,
evolutionarily speaking. So he has to
come from organic chemistry at some point.
Getting back to the previous slide,
I don't,
I don't really understand your thought
process about why we have their pow pow,
uh, chemical, you know, horizon
is that because we assume,
uh, all the, uh, you call it, Uhm, uh,
organism under the low carb.
You see,
we see new chase between the,
you know,
chemical compilation,
any proof
or evidence around there. So,
so I don't follow that. I, yeah,
I I I right with that because I was a
thought I was running out of time, but uh,
everything,
so obviously we are here.
You can think of that as a
spacetime diagrams so to speak.
We are here now at the tape of the o
carriers and we have our technology to
investigate biochemistry so we can go
about studying biochemistry many different
ways.
We can go and dissect an elephant and
understand the chemistry of the elephant,
or we can go through the fossil record
and look for fossilized organisms and we
investigated their biochemistry
so we can be looking for this.
We can look for deep,
deeply branching modern organisms that
we know existed a long time ago and we
can look at their biochemistry.
We can even look at our own biochemistry,
our own DNA, and look for what
we call molecular fossils staff.
There is in our DNA, don't think
of it, it's not trashed DNA,
but think of it as stuff that
at some point was useful.
It's not useful anymore type of thing.
Now really all that biochemistry,
whether it's modern fossil or ancient,
it goes back to looker.
Really.
You can also only trades back that to
this last universal common ancestor.
You can really not make any substantial
inference based on these biochemistry
about these biochemistry because
all of these records is known.
Obviously these biochemistry
evolved from this. Uh,
but the notion that all organisms have
DNA and RNA and their composition,
20 amino acids in their proteins,
the genetic code as we understand it all
that is because it comes from looker.
There could have been branches coming
out that had a different biochemistry or
we'll never know if they exist or
not cause they would have been lost.
We don't know if these organisms had
20 amino acids or a 10 amino acids. Uh,
we don't know.
We actually know that at some point
there were in DNA based people have
postulated the RNA world.
There was a wall,
there was a period of time where there
was no DNA biochemistry on earth.
It was RNA based.
They will have postulated
that RNA probably was not
the first generic molecule.
There was another different type of
molecule and people have even postulated a
metal enzymes,
enzymes based on magnesium and zinc
and other metal compounds that were the
first catalyzing compounds.
So the more you go back in time,
the more you realize that our biochemistry
is not representative really of these
biochemistry. It can only
be trace back to Luca. Uh,
and so that really means
that if you go to, I'll,
I'll give you the basic example. If I go
to Mars and I find a microbe that does,
Dan doesn't have DNA,
all I can tell you right now is
that this didn't come out of looker.
I see.
I don't know if it came out of these
branch that was not DNA base and I don't
know because they could
have been transferred or
transfer of live on Mars very
early on where there
was live on the earth,
very likely not DNA or RNA based.
It would look like are different from us
because the moment it gets transferred,
these evolutionary land gets broken,
then they're having time.
I see. So, so, so,
so I see that the purpose of the
research is trying to prove the second,
the form of a [inaudible] space.
The life you started,
you started of simply prove their life.
I break this,
I, I'd been advocating for that from a
science point of view and I didn't really
emphasize that.
But from a science point of view,
if you think a scientist
is mung soft knowledge,
people who are very
obsessed with knowledge base
discovering live is not really
the angle that's stuff for you know,
for explorers. I didn't
know at somebody put it. Um,
if you discover life on another planet,
I mean the bottom line is that as a
scientist we shouldn't think about the uh,
the Scott finding life as the angle.
That's when things begin.
The reason and I end it goes back to my
original argument about why we searching
for life. Why are we searching
for a second genesis of life?
One of the reasons because we will never
understand the origin of life on earth
unless we find a second
genesis plain and simple.
Second one is because we may never
understand all these process.
Third example is because
we buy a neighbor,
I understand the range of biochemical
possibilities out there and so finding
live is just what needs to happen for
us to start addressing those questions.
Yeah. Thank you very much. Thank you all.
It shouldn't be just about
searching or finding.
It should be about finding a second.
Genesis.
Um, I do have a quick question
from someone on the live stream.
So this is from Tyler.
He says a does hydrothermal vents on
the moon mean that it has a molten core?
Yes,
I
got that Tyler. So, uh,
obviously based on [inaudible]
bed, uh, the observation,
I guess I'll try, I'll
trace it back. So, uh,
as we travel back in time, um, the uh,
observation that we
can, uh, be sure about,
he's this silicon nano grains in the
plume of Enceladus. Now, uh, the best,
the most likely explanation for that.
So those Silicon Alley Grains
are hydrothermal vents at
the bottom of the ocean.
We haven't seen the events. It's true
everything we know about the moon though.
So Jazz,
the Dera hydrothermal vents there,
what that implies is that there is a
source of heat underneath the vents then
was likely source of heat is
some kind of molten core, uh,
due to the gravity pressures
due to the Saturn orbit.
That just creates an off, uh,
gravitational stress on the moon,
that it actually keeps the whole core
molten, just like the core of the earth.
Now, there could be additional sources
of heat, like radioactive decay,
a generates heat. Uh, but the fact that
we see evidence of hydrothermal activity,
it's a strong suggestion that the core
of the moon is in fact at least partially
molten and exactly as a source of energy,
which is something that has
been interesting as well
because that implies that
uh, probably Europa is the same
scenario. You're all busy going bigger,
but he has the same kind of a giant
planet and around causing gravity pools.
And so your boot x, you should, uh,
we should expect hydrothermal vents
at the bottom of Europe as well,
molten rock.
So a,
the composition of those months,
obviously it's not known because
we haven't analyzed them,
but based on everything we know, again,
that most likely starting materials,
we're not probably not different from
the starting materials of the earth. Con,
dried meteorites made rides of asteroids,
comets,
lots of IC stuff because they were far
away in the outskirts of the solar system.
So what's cold,
but it was probably stuff similar to
what generated the earth now on earth
because it's a big planet.
There are always plenty of room for,
and obviously we all started the same
way as a big molten ball of lava.
It's then was started that
way. Europa, the earth,
the earth was large enough
that when he called down,
there was plenty of room for
heavy stuff to fall off, uh,
because the cooling
process was probably slow.
And so when you call it slow,
it's like when you cook it slow,
things get better separated and
stuff like this. Uh, so, uh,
that's what happened on the
earth. The planet was big
enough, the cooling was low,
so heavy stuff like Aaron
and heavy metals drop to the,
to the core and formed our core
and sell it as is very small.
So it probably called very fast without
a chance for things to differentiate.
So what you have there in the core,
it's probably still very representative
of the original materials and the other,
the only staff that was,
uh,
kicked out in the cooling process was
probably stop there is volatile like water
and that's why you have an ocean of
liquid water on the surface and a lot of
methane and stuff,
which are all that stuff.
It doesn't take high temperatures for
that stuff to come out of the rock. Uh,
but the silica, the minerals, things
like these that formed these meteorites,
it's probably still more than,
they're not changing much.
I don't know why I stopped in this.
So not being very familiar with the,
this common ancestor of all life on earth.
Is that Luca meant to be like one cell
once back in time or just the origin?
Yeah, them question right. Uh,
we are now anything we can,
the only thing we can say for sure about
the origin of life on earth is that we
don't know, uh, it must have
happened, that's for sure.
And Lez well, there is the,
you know, the holographic
Unilever's and matrix. But, uh,
let's assume that it happened. Um, um,
there are theories on how you could
possibly envision it happening gradually.
Obviously it wasn't just like that.
Probably there was a combination of
a molecular complexity happening.
Eventually you need to self enclose
something so there is detached from the
environment and at some point that self
enclosed thing that you can probably not
still called live yet.
It has to have the ability of
replicating or passing on information,
which is really what defines life.
So at that point that's
when you talk about life.
But that transition was probably a part
of the ongoing process of evolution,
of chemical evolution,
how it happened.
We don't know if it was one cell or if
it was a protoplasm of goo covered with
stuff that we don't know.
It was probably not anything
like what we think today. Uh,
Tau rose who was one of the,
uh,
instigators of our modern understanding
of biochemistry at this grabs is in a
way that way.
I did,
I described it earlier in the process of
crystallization of lava crystallizing.
So it starts randomly and chaotically
and slowly as it cools down,
it becomes something more organized,
complex.
And eventually you end up with
a self replicating entity,
call it a cell or a guru.
And then that's when the process of
Darwinian evolution kicks and then
complexity, it just goes off the roof.
Um, but it's all part of the same.
And so it's really hard to
tell how it started, how it,
if we were to travel back to four
and a half billion years ago,
4.2 billion years ago,
uh,
it probably be be hard pressed to tell
whether it's life that we see there
versus very complex prebiotic chemistry
versus something entirely different.
Yeah. But we don't know. We need more
data points to really know that. And,
and that, I think that's a very
important point to keep in mind.
Why is important search
for life out there?
Because we will never know
unless we find a new genesis.
We can cook as many things,
but if we want in the lab,
it's very unlikely we'll generate life
in the lab, uh, from zero, from scratch.
And so, uh, hopefully,
hopefully happens. But, uh,
but my guess is that not until
we find a second genesis,
we can really understand the way
life on earth originated. Cool.
And what's Luca stand for and
what, what does it need, Luca,
what does it stand for?
Look at last universal common ancestor.
So my question is what are
the options for detecting
biotic organic evolution and exoplanets?
Right now it's an, it's very
unlikely we, we can do it. Uh,
but I assuming unlimited funds
and technology that doesn't exist,
you could think of, you
could search for, um,
chemical. Does that clear?
We an atmosphere in the
atmosphere of exoplanets.
So obviously the first thing you would
do it would be because there is so many
of them,
you would shorten the list and you
would focus on the ones that are close,
right distance from the sun,
the rice, the right distance,
define as the distance that allows
liquid water to be stable on the surface.
So you focus on those. And then in
those you could search for, I mean,
the atmosphere,
so coexist enough gases,
they shouldn't coexist unless something
is pumping them in the atmosphere and
the earth. You have the example of
oxygen, there is high abundance.
There is no a biotic way of making that
much oxygen in, you know, on a planet.
Uh, although people have come up
with clever ways of doing it. Uh,
but the fact that you have oxygen and
methane coexisting all the time means that
both are being produced because
otherwise they would emulate each other.
They would cancel the other.
I meant more. Is it
possible to detect this, um,
these weird distributions
of carbon chains? Not that
we need samples for that.
We need, we need stuff.
We need to be able to inject something
in an instrument to do these types of
detectors.
We can,
we can certainly take carbon hydrogen
so we can detect like we've done in,
uh, uh, interstellar space. You
can detect certain compounds.
Um, but mostly you detect these
seal to methane and all that stuff.
Uh,
the abundance of this.
So I guess I'll give you another
example. We've, we've done,
we've gone for the thought exercise of
we wanted to detect those molecules on
Enceladus coming out of the plume.
What should be our limit of detection
so that if we don't find anything we can
create a confident that
there is nothing in there.
And I think our leaders
estimate was we should be,
our instrument should be able
to detect femto molar abundance.
That's 10 to the minus
15, uh, concentrations.
Um, in order to be able to tell, well,
you know what, there is nothing there.
Uh, and to do that we need the best
instruments on earth and we need a very
complicated way of collecting enough
material from the ocean that we can
actually inject into the instruments doing
that remotely with telescopes. It's a,
it's a show stopper and the
Bra. And so, uh, the, the,
the fact that you don't see them wouldn't
mean that they're not there because
your limit of detection
would be so inaccurate.
You can only say that based
on your limit of detection,
you can see trees on whatever planet
you have out there. Not even, I mean,
other people have proposed to
look at the surveys and, uh,
like if you look at the
surface of the earth,
you could detect chlorophyll for example,
but you need a planet like the earth and
you need a satellite orbiting the earth,
the planet.
You can do that from our Alpha Centauri.
Um, if I may another question.
So you mentioned that, um,
it's the stuff in our solar system
was made from a previous star.
I wonder what the chances are of life, um,
becoming recycled through that process.
Yeah. Uh, people have looked
into that both in terms of the,
the problem of transfer of light
between planets or live surviving.
And again, it's, um, uh,
you can always fit a model
to anything you want. Uh,
but life is very resilient and surviving
in dormant state that we know. Uh,
and there are scenarios when you think
about the transfer of planet of life
between Earth and Mars,
there are plausible scenarios of rocks
moving from one plan to the next in time
scales that are shorter than what we know.
Microbes can survive doormen
that much we can say. Uh,
and when he comes to commentary Panspermia
so life come originating in the end,
it really comes back to,
it comes down to how big a chunk of
material you have floating around. Uh,
because really what kills out there
is not the cold is the radiation. Uh,
time kills eventually,
but it takes a long time for time
to kill and nothing else. Uh,
radiation is what really
kills you quickly are there.
So if you're a microbe sitting in the,
in the nucleus of a big asteroid and
we talk in a few kilometers in size,
you'll probably will never see an
obligation to kill you over hundreds of
millions of years. Uh, and so, uh,
it's, I'm oversimplifying a bit,
but um, you can always find a plausible
scenario where a microbe could survive.
Bottom line, I don't think we should
expect that to be the first explanation.
But the problem is that
you can rule it out.
There's no amount of hand waving you can
do to rule that possibility out until
you go and you find a second
genesis of life on Mars truly.
And then you can confidently say that
life on earth didn't originate out of that
comment or that commentary or
that he wasn't transfer. Uh,
as long as you don't find a
second geneses that quest,
that possibility is always going to be
open, which is a very important thing.
I don't want to keep you, but it's a
very, I didn't mention that, but it's a,
it really speaks to how we
search for live as well.
Because when you think about
a second genesis and how,
and to distinguish between the second
genesis and a possible common origin,
not every bio signature is equal.
If you find, if you go to Mars,
I don't know if you guys
know about stromatolites, uh,
there, these are microbial.
There are rugs there are made or by
microbial activity and their fossilized.
And we say, I mean the fossil record, uh,
and would you see in the fossil
record is just the shape of the rock.
That looks weird,
but it is nothing in that world that
speaks of life other than the shape. Now,
if we go to Mars,
actually I'm too far away.
If we go to Mars and we find a
stromatolite these weird shape,
maybe you can tell there was
life on Mars at some point,
but you can't tell how we originated.
You will never tell based on
the shape of stromatolites,
whether it's a common origin or
a second genesis. And so, uh,
that might be one of those things that
happen 20 years from now when we find it.
And then we get all excited and
we published our paper in nature,
and the next day is like, wait a
second, what did this guy come from?
And then we have to send another
mission to search for biochemistry.
And so I'd really matters how we think
about the search for life before we start
searching for it.
Because you can end up with many years
of time and money not spent the right
way. I'll still be happy if we
find a store model. Omar's, but
yeah.
Thank you.
[inaudible].